♪ ♪
>> THE DEBACLE IS GETTING WORST.
THE 2020 DEMOCRAT IS GRILLED
ABOUT HER NATIVE-AMERICAN
HERITAGE.
>> YOU SAID YOU WERE A
NATIVE-AMERICAN ON DOCUMENTS
WHEN YOU WERE A PROFESSOR AT
HARVARD.
WHY DID YOU DO THAT?
>> IT'S WHAT I BELIEVE.
LIKE I SAID, WHAT I LEARNED FROM
MY FAMILY.
>> WHEN DID YOU FIND OUT YOU
WEREN'T?
>> WELL, I AM NOT A PERSON OF
POWER.
>> WAS THERE ANY BENEFIT TO
THAT?
>> NO.
THEY DID A FULL INVESTIGATION.
NOTHING ABOUT MY FAMILY EVER
AFFECTED ANY JOB I EVER GOT.
>> YOU DIDN'T GET A DISCOUNT IN
COLLEGE?
>> NO.
>> YOU SOUND LIKE THE WHITE
WOMAN WHO PRETENTED TO BE BLACK.
>> THIS IS WHAT I LEARNED FROM
MY FAMILY.
>> THAT WAS AWFUL.
>> YOUR FAMILY TOLD YOU WERE
NATIVE-AMERICAN?
HE IS LOOKING AT HER.
SHE IS LOOKING LIKE ELIZABETH
WARREN AND GOES YEAH.
HOW LONG DID YOU HOLD ON TO
THAT?
IT'S JUST SO BIZARRE.
IF PEOPLE SEE THROUGH THIS
STUFF.
ALL ANYBODY WANTS IS FOR PEOPLE
TO BE AUTHENTIC.
EVERYONE TALKS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT WHO MANY PEOPLE SAY IS
A BIG LIAR.
THERE ARE SOMETHING AUTHENTIC
ABOUT HIM WHETHER YOU LOVE HIM
OR HATE HIM.
THIS KIND OF STUFF SMACKS OF
THAT UNCOMFORTABLE FEELING WHEN
YOU FEEL LIKE SOMEBODY IS TRYING
TO BE LIKE PART OF A PROTECTED
CLASS AND I THAT ARE NOT.
>> WHAT MADE IT MORE POWERFUL
THIS IS NOT A PROFESSIONAL MEDIA
INTERVIEW.
THIS IS A RELAXED GROUP OF GUYS
ON THE RADIO THAT SPEAK LIKE
REGULAR PEOPLE.
SHE CAN GET AWAY WITH HER DANCES
AND TALKING POINTS IF YOU DO
SOMETHING ON A NETWORK.
YOU CAN'T SPEAK HONESTLY ABOUT
WHAT YOU DID BECAUSE YOU LIED
TEMPERATURE COMES ACROSS SO
OBVIOUS.
>> WELL, THE GUY IS NOT JUST ANY
INTERVIEWER.
THAT SHOW IS A BIG HIT.
>> BUT HE IS CASUAL AND
DISARMING.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
ALL OF THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO GET
ON THAT SHOW RIGHT NOW.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY --
>> HE DID A GOOD INTERVIEW.
>> HE DID A TERRIFIC INTERVIEW.
BUT HE GOT TO THE HEART AND SOUL
OF THE MATTER.
YOU LOOK AT THE QUESTIONS IT'S
BULLET POINT FASHION.
WE THINK YOU HAVE DECEIVED US.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT.
TO THE POLITICS OF IT, IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WHO WOULD
VOTE FOR ELIZABETH WARREN WILL
SAY I WON'T VOTE FOR ELIZABETH
WARREN.
IF ELIZABETH WARREN GETS THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP BEGINS CALLING
HER
>> SHE IS IN A FIGHT AGAINST
BERNIE SANDERS FOR SECOND PLACE.
ALL OF THIS MATTERS IF YOU HAVE
24 CANDIDATES AND PEOPLE ARE
SHOPPING AROUND.
SHE IS THE ONLY ONE THAT PUT
FORWARD DETAILED POLICY
PROPONENTS.
SHE IS A RIGHT WOMAN WHO LISTED
HERSELF AS A NATIVE-AMERICAN TO
GET A BOOST IN HER IVY LEAGUE
EDUCATION.
SHE TRIED TO OVERCOME IT.
I DON'T THINK SHE CONNECTED THIS
TODAY.
SHE IS UNCOMFORTABLE BECAUSE
IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE TO WATCH IT.
THE ONE THING, DONALD TRUMP CAN
CALL HER POCAHONTAS AND IT'S HIS
FAKE LAUGH, BUT COMING FROM
SOMEONE ELSE.
SOMEONE ON THE LEFT OR ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT THING.
I WONDER IF KAMALA HARRIS OR
BOOKER OR BERNIE SANDERS WILL
TRY TO GET A LEG UP WILL USE
THIS AGAINST HER?
>> DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD
HAPPEN IN THE DEBATE.
>> THIS IS ALLOWING THAT TO
HAPPEN.
I THINK HE HAS AN ALLEGIANCE TO
ANOTHER CANDIDATE AND WATCHES
"THE FIVE" BECAUSE IN OCTOBER
2018, WE GAVE ELIZABETH WARREN
THE RACHAEL AWARD IN MY
MONOLOGUE.
HE IS LIKE A LASER BEAM.
I WOULD NOT WANT TO BE
INTERVIEWED BY HIM.
HE LISTENED TO HER PATRONIZING
SPIEL AND KICKED BACK.
THAT MADE IT PAINFUL BECAUSE IT
WAS SO ON THE LEVEL AND
PERSISTENT.
YOU COULD ARGUE IT HELPS HER IN
THE SENSE THAT NO ONE HITS HER
BORDER POLICIES.
EVERYBODY FOCUSES ON POCAHONTAS
AND NOT THE FACT SHE WANTS TO
RE-DISTRIBUTE ALL OF YOUR MONEY.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
POCAHONTAS AND THE POKING OF
POCAHONTAS, IT'S THE FABRICATION
OF PROOF FROM LAUGHABLE DATA
THAT WE COVERED WHEN SHE HIRED
THAT GUY TO REFUTE THE DONALD
TRUMP STUFF.
THAT WAS THE BIGGER LIE.
NOT WHAT SHE TRIED TO GET
THROUGH COLLEGE AND GET ALL OF
THIS FREE STUFF.
SHE FABRICATED THIS STORY.
>> IT'S NOT THE DATA.
THE DATA BACKS YOUR POINT.
SHE IS ZERO.
>> YES.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE POINT.
TO MY MIND THE AMAZING THING
ABOUT ELIZABETH WARREN IS
DESPITE ALL OF THIS SHE IS
NUMBER 3 IN THE POLLS.
SHE HAS BEEN EATING INTO BERNIE
SANDERS.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT'S BECAUSE
OF THE ARE THE CANDIDATES?
>> NO, I THINK IT'S I HAVE A
PLAN.
SHE HAS POLICY.
SHE BURNED OUT A NICHE FOR
HERSELF.
SHE AS A WEBSITE WHERE YOU CAN
GO ON AND SEE HOW MUCH OF YOUR
STUDENT DEBT WOULD BE ERASED
UNDERER PLAN.
THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
>> EVERYBODY WANTS TO GO BACK TO
THE DNA PROBLEM.
>> YOU DO.
>> NO.
CHARLEMAIN JUST DID THAT.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THE LOW CROWDS
JOE BIDEN GETS, BUT ELIZABETH
WARRENS THAT DOES.
>> SHE SAID EVEN NOW I THOUGHT I
WAS A COUPLE PERCENT
NATIVE-AMERICAN.
I STILL CLAIMED I WAS ALL
>> 12% OF DEMOCRAT VOTERS SAY
THIS IS AN ISSUE.
>> IT'S ABOUT CHARACTER.
IT'S ABOUT THE CHOICES YOU ARE
MAKING.
IF YOU HAVE A CHOICE BETWEEN 24
PEOPLE AND WHO DO YOU CROSS OFF
YOUR LIST?